خلينا نبتدي مع وقفتنا اليوم مع اخبار
تويتر امس تكلمنا انه خلاص تم البدء
بتنفيذ الاشتراك بالعلامه الزرقاء في عدد
من الدول واستعرضنا التطورات في الموضوع
لكن اللي صار انه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز نشر
التقرير مفادو انه تويتر راح ياجل البدء
بتنفيذ الاشتراك في علامه التوثيق لغايه
الامتحان من الانتخابات النصفيه يوم
الثلاثاء وهذه الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه هتحدد لي من الكافه
الديمقراطيين ولا الجمهوريين فعلشان ما
يصير تلاعب وجؤه لخبطه في الانتخابات تم
تاجيل قرار تفعيل الاشتراك في العلامه
الزرقاء لغايه ما تخلص الانتخابات اشتراك
العلامه اتاجل لكن في شيء لغى هو تسريحه
عشرات من الموظفين ففي مصادر خاصه من داخل
شركه تويتر قالت لي بلوك انه تويتر طلب من
بعض الموظفين اللي تم
بالخطا يوم الجمعه العوده الى عملهم لانه
تبين بعدين انه في اشخاص تم تسريحهم من
عملهم من دون ما يطلعوا على خبراتهم في
العمل وقدرات وملكتشفوا انها ضروري
للميزات اللي ماسك ناوي يزود تويتر فيها
لذلك قررت الشركه انها ترجعهم للعمل وطبعا
شركه وتركي كانت صرحت يوم الجمعه 50% من
موظفيها ومع هذه القرارات ال مستمر في
نشاطه على تويتر فال تغريدات ما توجبت وهو
جالس يشرح التويتر راح يكون المنصه الاكثر
مصداقيه ودقه في العالم وتابع نشره
تحديثات اللي بيعملها في المنصه وهذه
المره في سياستها فاعلن انه راح يوقف كل
الحسابات اللي بتقل المشاهير بطريقه ساخره
من دون ما تعلن وتحدث انه هذا الحساب هو
حساب محاك ساخر وكمان اعلن انه اي ريوز
راح يتم تغييره راح يخسر العلامه الزرقاء
لحين التحقق من الحساب واكد انه في السابق
كان تويتر بيبعث رسائل تحذير قبل التعليق
الحساب اما السياسه الجديده لتويتر فما
فيها رسائل تحذير ابدا وبيتم تعليق الحساب
مباشره وعلى فكره من بعد ما اتكلم ماسكه
عن هذه السياسه الجديده وانتحال الهويه
الصحفي بن بن جونس نتكلم عن محاوله
الممثله الامريكيه كاتي جريفن بانها تعمل
حساب باسم الماسك ونشر تغريده وصوره او هو
نشر تحديدا تغريده وصوره بتبين انه تم
تعليق الحساب بشكل كامل وكتبت تغيير
الثانيه انه هذا الشيء صار من بعد ما تم
الاعلان على او عن سياسه التحقق من منتحلي
الشخصيه
[موسيقى]
وضعنا في الاستديو احمد الشيخ المتخصص في
المنصات الاجتماعيه اهلا فيك معنا كثير
تغيرات جلسه بتصير بشكل يومي كل ساعه
عندنا تغيير جديد الان بعد ما كان جالس
بيقول هتدفع حتدفع حتدفعوا رجع قال حناجل
الموضوع عشان الانتخابات النصفيه
الانتخابات النصفيه
تراجع هو تراجع في مساله البلوتشيك او
التحكم في العلامه الزرقاء وايضا تراجع في
مساله الموظفين مساله التاجيل لما بعد
الانتخابات النصفيه هو مجرد حجه هو طبعا
شايف ان الاوضاع دلوقت غير مستقره وغير
مهيئه لفرد هذا الاجراء في مشكله كبيره في
هذا الاجراء هي فكره منتحلي الشخصيه اللي
كانت تكلم عنها في اطار اخر دلوقتي تويتر
المفروض هي اللي هتحقق في شخصيات الناس
المشكله دلوقتي ان اللي عنده علامه زرقاء
ده هو شخص معروف صح صح ممثل مغني ما حدش
سياسي متحدث رسمي شخص معروف وبالتالي لو
في حد انتحل شخصيته الناس هتعرف وهتبلغ
تويتر ولكن لو في حد قدم نفسه بصفته محمد
احمد وقدم باسبور بصفه محمد احمد وبدا
يحتال على الناس او يعمل اي حاجه مخالفه
للقوانين على تويتر تحت اسم محمد احمد وهو
واخد العلامه الزرقاء طيب مين هيتحمل
المسؤوليه فيها هذه اللحظه هل هو الشخص
اللي احنا مش عارفينه ولا هو تويتر وهل
تويتر يعني يمتلك ال- ال- الريسورسيز او
الامكانيات عشان يحقق الشخصيات ده في ناس
بتتحيل على انظمه الهجره وبيزوره باسبورات
فعلشان كده قالوا ماسك وتويتر شاف ان
المساله كبيره جدا احباب للاحتيال
والاجرام تحت الستار العلامه الزرقاء
وبالتالي كان لابد ان يتراجع ولو مؤقتا
يعني الموضوع انت بتقول انه مش بس
الانتخابات والتلاعب في الانتخابات هو
السبب في هذا كان مجرد عنوان يعني طب بس
الانتخابات الان هتكون يعني
هو مجمدها يعني فتره قصيره يعني لازم
يلاقي حل سريعه بالضبط وده يؤكد ان
الانتخابات ليست هي السبب الوحيد في في
اسباب اخرى طبعا مساله للانتخابات هي اللي
تكلمت عنها بلومبيرغ ولكن في مصادر اخرى
بتتكلم عن التحديات الاخرى يومين
والانتخابات هتخلص وبالتالي لهم ماسك لازم
يلاقي حل اخر في يعني في تحديات كبيره
بتواجه مساله العلامه الزرقاء خصوصا من
المشاهير لان المشاهير شايفين ان اي احد
دلوقت هيبقى عنده علامه زرقاء وبالتالي هي
فقدت قيمتها هو في الاول كان واخد العلامه
الزرقاء باعتبار ان هو شخصيه عامه دلوقت
تويتر في في بياناته الرسميه وحتى على ابل
بيقول للناس انت مش لازم تكون شخصيه عامه
علشان تاخد علامه
دولار
اذا فهي كده فقدت قيمتها وفي ناس كثير جدا
بيقولوا خلاص مش هندفع ومش عايزين العلامه
الزرقاء لان هي كده فقدت قيمتها بشكل بس
الموضوع الوحيد ان احنا بنتكلم كمان عن
تسريحه الموظفين واعاده بعض الموظفين انه
لا تعالوا انتم انفصلتوا بالغل هذا النوع
من التضارب يعني كيف الواحد يقدر يفسر
ظهوره من شخص زي الماسك متمارس في الاداره
شخص ذكي جدا كل هذا الكلام كيف يعمل هذه
التناقضات ماسك دلوقتي يعني بيدير المعركه
بعده وسائل او مدفوعا بعده دوافع هو عنده
دلوقتي هو بيستعين بمين هو بيستعين بعده
شخصيات بعضها من تويتر وبعضها من خارج
تويتر من شركاته الاخرى من تسلا وسبيس اكس
وغيرها والمفروض ان اهل تويتر همم يعني
ادرى بشعبها يعني كان المفروض المشكله
من بره يعني واضح ان هي لخبطه الموضوع
اكتر احد الموظفين كان كاتب بيقول ان هو
سال المدير بتاعه قال له لو جاء لك
ايميلات خلال الفتره الجايه فانت معنا لو
ما جاء لكش يبقى انت مرفود اذا المديرين
نفسهم ما كانوش عارفين مين اللي قاعد ومين
اللي ماشي مساله تمت يعني يلا نتخلص يلا
نتخلص من اللي بيتعاملوا مع مسائل كذا
وكذا وكذا ده بيحصل يعني الناس طبعا
استغربا ده هيحصل في مؤسسه كبيره ولكن في
مؤسسات كبيره جدا مترهله وفيها اخطاء
كبيره وبتحصل فيها بلاوي بيوصلوا للماكم
يعني وبالتالي فده ممكن يحصل في مؤسسه زي
تويتر ويحصل في مؤسسه من مؤسسات الى
الماسك الى الماسك كمان واضح انه بيدير
المساله بشكل شخصي يعني شوفي حجم التويتس
اللي بيكتبها كل يوم يعني ده احنا انا
وانت ما عندناش وقت نكتب كل هذه السويس ما
حدش فينا بيكتب هذا العالم
في اغنى رجل في العالم بيكتب كل هذه
التويتس ده ده برده
قبل كده تحليل نفسي لاحد المحللين نفسيين
الامريكان قال ان قالوا ماسك بيهرب الى
هذه التغريدات هو عنده حاجات اخرى حاجات
اخرى بتشغله بتشغله نفسيا وصحيه وماليا
وكل حاجه هو بيهرب الى التغريد لانه
الماسك برده عنده استراتيجيه مهمه جدا ودي
بيتبعها دائما ان هو يتصدر عناوين الاخبار
بالحق والباطل في 2018 قال للناس انا
هاعمل الغواصه اللي هتروح تايلاند تنقذ
الاطفال من الك صح ولا شوفنا ايلون ماسك
ساعتها اختفى هو والغواصه بتاعته ما حصلتش
الماسك قال للناس هعمل لكم شريحه بدل مثلا
مثلا
نيوروليك هذه شغال عليها
زي الصواريخ اللي هو عملها فعلا ولا
مصيرها زي الغواصه احنا لسه مش عارفين
مشروع المستقبل
لو تطلعنا على وثائق المحكمه وهي متاحه
دلوقت على الانترنت المحكمه اللي كان
المفروض تنطلق يوم 17/10 هنلاقي اثبات
انقلد مصر حذف رسائل خاصه كان بيتبادل
الرسائل مع المسؤولين بتوع تويتر ومع
المسؤولين عن اداره الصفقه ولكن حذف هذه
الرسائل علشان ده يلزق نفسه ولكن خلاص ال-
ال- الطرف الثاني كان عارف هذه الرسائل
محكمه اثبتت انه يتهرب من التزاماته
وبالتالي اي وعده هياخذوا الى الماسك على
نفسه هو غير ملزم به عادي ممكن اتراجع عنه
بالضبط طيب يعني مذهل هذا الموضوع واحنا
لسه هنشوف كثير بنشكرك على وجودك معنا كان
معنا في الاستديو احمد الشيخ المتخصص في
المنصات الاجتماعيه شكرا لك